[Norvig] It looks like that means that we're going to have to use something more complicated
than just this ranking from 0 to 8.
I'm going to propose a couple possibilities.
One possibility would be to continue to return integers but to use bigger ones.
So let's take an example of what we want to compare.
Let's say we have 2 hands that are 4 of a kind.
One has four 9s and a 5, and the other one has four 3s and a 2.
We want this hand to rank higher.
Under the old formulation, they would both be ranked as a 7
because 7 is the rank for 4 of a kind.
So if we want to change that to use a different type of result,
we could use integers and we could say,
let's say, 70905 and 70302,
so the 9 and the 5 to represent that this is 4 of a kind of 9s with a 5 left over
and the 3 and the 2 to say it's 4 of a kind of 3s with a 2 left over.
We could use real numbers.
We could say 7.0905 or 7.0302.
Another possibility is we could use tuples.
We could use 7, 9, 5 versus 7, 3, 2.
A tuple is just like a list,
except it can't be modified and it has a slightly different set of operations associated with it.
But basically, it just means a grouping of 3 values in this case.
What I want you to tell me is out of these 3 possibilities,
which one of them would work at all
and which one of them seems best in terms of being most convenient
and easy to work with within our program?